[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
bonjour vous voyez ce petit légaux
c'était moi il ya un an et demi quand
j'étais en quête de sens
quand j'ai quitté mon job en plein
changement
mais de quoi parle-t-on le changement
pour moi le changement c'est faire avec
ce qui est autre différent non
maîtrisables car inconnue et sans aucune
garantie
le changement et stimule il ébranle un
il déséquilibre il est ce que l'on en
fera avec le temps
oui parce qu'il s'agit bien ici de
prendre le temps de se poser dans un
monde où tout s'accélère on peut se
retrouver coincé entre ce que les autres
nous renvoie nous influencent les normes
de société et ce que l'on a au fond de
nous il ya comme un décalage en quête de
sens pour beaucoup on recherche cette
cohérence entre ce que nous faisons
qui nous sommes ce dans quoi on se sent
bien et utile on parlerait même
finalement d'une certaine quête
d'équilibré il ya 74 % des français quoi
envie de contribuer à résoudre un enjeu
de société mais qui ne passe pas à
l'action
par manque de temps de confiance en soi
ou de peur liée à l'argent mais c'est
énorme
trois quarts d'entre nous qui ont envie
d'agir mais qui ne passe pas à l'action
alors qu'est ce qui nous manque pour
passer à l'étape suivante qu'est ce qui
nous manque pour nous engager nous
épanouir pleinement
on ne prend pas assez le temps de se
poser et d'écouter ce qu'on a au fond
des tripes et d'en faire quelque chose
alors à tous ceux qui recherchent sans
si essentiel dans nos vies j'ai une
bonne nouvelle c'est possible seulement
voilà vous devez déjà le savoir il n'y a
pas de recette miracle je venu
aujourd'hui vous partagez de clés de
clés qui m'ont énormément aidé dans ce
parcours
ces derniers mois la première clé c'est
pour pouvoir agir
encore faut-il savoir prendre soin de
soi
j'ai travaillé sept ans dans le
marketing bon alors ça allait voilà
c'est quelque chose qui me plaisait mais
il manquait toujours quelque chose
ce petit sa petite étincelle qui faisait
que je me sentais vraiment à ma place à
ligne avec ce que je faisais et puis un
jour j'ai quitté mon job sans plan b moi
qui suis ultra organisés
ça me ressemble pas du tout alors je
préconise pas du tout cette solution
loin de là c'est juste mon parcours
ça a été le fruit d'un an de rencontres
d'initiatives et des changes
en fait je me rendais compte que j'avais
envie de m'engager moi aussi pour
contribuer à rendre notre monde meilleur
plus juste et plus durable
alors j'ai proposé à mon entreprise de
porter des projets entrepreneuriaux
sociaux et solidaire l'intrapreneuriat
c'est comme l'entrepreneuriat mais dans
une entreprise on porte des projets en
lien avec la stratégie mise en place est
en dehors du cadre et la première porte
premier non
bon je laisse passer quelques mois et
puis bah voila je reviens à la charge
parce que je sens vraiment ses
convictions fortes en moi que on peut
faire bouger les lignes de l'intérieur
je propose de créer un service
développement durable et d'innovation
sociale dans un groupe où il ya quinze
mille collaborateurs et énormément de
choses à faire
j'en suis persuadé et la deuxième porte
deuxième non dits perrine écoute enfin
c'est pas c'est pas la stratégie
actuelle en fait c'est pas les priorités
de l'entreprise et moi là je me dis mais
j'étais tellement convaincus que ben là
je tombe des nues et je je perds goûts
et à tous je suis démotivé jeu là je me
sens vraiment très mal j'arrive au
boulot la boule au ventre je deviens en
pilote automatique je perds confiance en
tout en mes capacités en ce que je suis
je commence en fait ce qu'on appelle un
bord à août alors le burn out c'est
l'épuisement professionnel dit au
surinvestissement et en fait il ya un
autre phénomène qui s'appelle le burn
out et donc on s'épuise en s'ennuyant
mais ça paraît dingue on s'épuise en
s'ennuyant bah si c'est possible et donc
ça m'est arrivé et j'ai quitté mon job
pour me reposer et me reconnecter
vraiment à ce qu'il faisait sens pour
moi alors ce que je
et comme des échecs ces deux initiatives
n'ont abouti en fait c'est des normes
apprentissage pour ça je le dis avec le
recul et ces deux normes apprentissage
puisque j'ai réalisé que pour porter des
initiatives de manière durable
encore fallait-il que j'ai la bonne
posture confiance en moi que je
m'entoure des bonnes personnes que j'ai
les bons outils et c'était pas forcément
le cas je deviens exploratrice donc en
quittant mon job je deviens exploratrice
du jour au lendemain et la découverte de
tellement de choses nourrissante et je
pense vraiment qu'on n'a pas besoin de
quitter son job pour passer par cette
phase là mais en tout cas c'est encore
une fois mon parcours j'ai été à plein
de conférence j'ai participé à plein de
formation je suis partie de moi en
voyage engagés aux philippines j'ai
découvert la méditation voilà bref j'ai
vraiment reconnecter à ce qui était
essentiel ce dans quoi je me sentais
bien j'ai identifié ce qui me faisait
souffrir et j'ai peu à peu à mon rythme
retrouvé goût et trouver ma place
en fait j'ai pris le temps de m'asseoir
cinq minutes sur un banc avec moi et là
je vous pose cette question est ce que
vous avez déjà pris ce temps de
réfléchir vous d'expérimenter d'écouter
ceux dont ce pourquoi vous avez du
plaisir quel verbe ou caractérise
finalement est ce que ces écoutes et
transmettre organisé rencontre est
soigné est-ce que vous avez des rêves
des motivations profondes et est ce que
il ya des peurs des blocages qui vous
empêche mais que vous pourriez surpasser
pour y arriver
ah non en fait on nous a pas appris à se
poser ces questions-là
pourtant elles sont essentielles je
parlerai ici d'un égoïsme vient
bienveillant l'égoïsme bienveillant pour
moi ce n'est pas l'égoïsme je prends
tout pour moi je fais pour moi je
réfléchis pour moi non non c'est
vraiment je prends soin de ce qui est
important pour moi pour pouvoir prendre
soin des autres
de notre environnement on parle beaucoup
de notre du développement durable de
notre planète
quel équilibre entre les ressources
qu'on en fait mais en fait il serait
aussi grand temps de penser à notre
propre développement durable à nous la
deuxième clé s'est trouvé son équilibre
savoir prendre soin de soi pour trouver
son équilibre et agir il ya quelques
semaines je me retrouve en plein
d'affaires atteint à quelques centaines
de mètres du sol donc moi qui ai le
vertige voilà c'est déjà un bon petit
challenge et un moment donné je perds
équilibre donc je me retrouve la main
sur la paroi et les deux pieds
complètement dans le vide
donc c'est un peu l'angoissé pour ne pas
dire beaucoup et j'ai mon moniteur qui
ne donne quelques conseils donc je
[Musique]
prends le temps de retrouver mon
équilibre
voilà et j'y arrive je me fait confiance
je lui fais confiance
et quelques minutes plus tard quand je
me retrouve enfin sur la terre ferme
il va me dire cette phrase qui résonne
vraiment en moi il me dit perrine tu
sais dans chaque déséquilibre on
retrouve un nouvel équilibre mais c'est
tellement ça en fait je me suis rendu
compte que dans le changement le
déséquilibre il était nécessaire pour
reconstruire créer du neuf
faire bouger les lignes on en a besoin
oui mais jusqu'où on a besoin aussi de
retrouver notre équilibre un moment
donné et pour ça il ya l'importance de
nos ancrage de nos ressources qui peut
nous aider dans mon nouveau projet
professionnel dans lequel j'ai trouvé ma
place et je me sens plus que bien et
épanouie et ben je me suis retrouvé de
nouveau un déséquilibre parce que
c'est vivant ça bouge et je me suis
rendu compte qu'on donnait que je
mettais le curseur professionnels
beaucoup trop loin
et bah en fait j'avais plus de 10
personnes
je ne voyais plus mes amis ni même mon
couple et ça a été très dur pour moi
cette prise de conscience à un moment
donné je regardais mon conjoint je me
disais mais en fait c'est quoi nos
projets qu'est-ce qu'on partage
maintenant et pourtant c'est un élément
essentiel dans ma vie et pour porter mon
projet j'ai besoin de de cette ressource
pour le porter de manière durable
alors j'ai pu faire un pas de côté et je
me suis dit qu'est ce qui est important
pour moi j'ai pris le temps à mon rythme
de me poser la question de redéfinir mes
priorisation ça a pris du temps
je suis passé par des émotions pas
évidente mais voilà je suis sorti de cet
entre deux nations et cet équilibre
comme je disais il est vivant il est à
entretenir car chaque jour est une
petite vie alors une fois qu'on a pris
soin de soi qu'on a compris ce qui était
important pour soi et qu'on a trouvé
notre équilibre
alors on s'autorise pleinement à
s'épanouir et à rayonner mais parce
qu'en fait notre propre développement
durable à nous il ya un impact positif
des multiplicateurs il veut discret mais
il est énorme et on a même envie d'être
utile
ça peut inspirer la bienveillance
l'intelligence collective le mieux faire
le mieux vivre ensemble
en fait c'est génial il ça dans sa vie
personnelle comme dans sa vie
professionnelle
chacun avec ses possibilités ses
contraintes
ça peut être vraiment des petites des
moyennes ou des grandes actions
ça peut être proposé de créer un
composteur dans un immeuble comme
proposer des formats de réunions plus
collaborative dans une entreprise comme
c'est investir dans des associations
comme porter un projet d'entreprenariat
social enfin y'a vraiment mille et une
façons de s'épanouir et d'être utile
mais encore faut-il prendre le temps de
trouver cet équilibre trouvé son
équilibre
alors j'ai
je suis toujours en chemin ça peut être
facile tous les jours
j'ai ri j'ai pleuré j'ai aimé j'ai haï
j'ai refoulé j'ai ouvert jusqu'à me
perdre iron man 2 et je me suis dit que
j'avais envie de retrouver cet équilibre
pour pouvoir agir aller de l'avant faire
avec ce que je suis et ce que je deviens
bref trop de la place aujourd'hui je
porte un projet qui a vraiment du sens
pour moi
non pas parce que je suis passé
uniquement par cette étape mais aussi
parce que j'ai compris ce pour quoi
j'avais envie de m'engager et ce qui me
faisait vraiment du bien je porte un
projet qui a pour mission d'accompagner
justement les personnes en quête de sens
et envie d'agir pour se poser les bonnes
questions et passer à l'action
et ça vaut vraiment le coup en fait de
faire ce chemin et si votre pouvoir
était dans votre équilibre dans cette
cohérence de vie et quand je dis le mot
pouvoir s'est pas uniquement le verbe
pouvoir passer à l'action se mettre en
mouvement c'est aussi le mot pouvoir
votre force vos talents et si votre
pouvoir était dans votre équilibre à
vous alors oui j'en suis convaincu tout
changement commence par soi
commence par un premier pas votre
premier pas et vous quel sera le vôtre
dès aujourd'hui merci
[Applaudissements]